The function f of
x is defined as f
of x is equal to
49 minus x squared.
Find the value of f of 5.
So whenever you're
dealing with a function,
you take your input.
In this case, our input
is going to be our 5.
We input it into our
little function box,
and we need to get our output.
And they defined the
function box here
as whatever your input is,
take that, square it, and then
subtract it from 49.
So f of 5, every time I
see an x here, since f of x
is equal to this,
every time I see an x,
I would replace
it with the input.
So f of 5 is going
to be equal to 49
minus-- instead of
writing x squared,
I would write 5 squared.
So this is equal to 49 minus 25.
And 49 minus 25 is equal to 24.
And we are done.